can you uh recap the story about the the
the guy's house you went to that had the
shark in the pool yeah yeah man that was
this guy Sam McGee and he was a [__]
he was a legend so he basically
he went long gold I think it was
um I forget when when but right before
he went to LA and I don't know he ended
up cashing out for around 700 million
bucks that's That's How The Story Goes
and he [__] goes to LA and he's got a
degenerative disease where he knows he's
gonna die this guy's got 700 million
dollars and he basically [__] just
does everything that a guy that you know
[__] may not see tomorrow does right
and so like [__] guy said he was
gonna like stock his house in Versace
tile and you know we thought he was full
of [__] he's like I ordered it from
Italy it's four million dollars like
yeah like sometimes you like you know
we're just like blow off stuff that he
would say but then sure enough this
stuff came in and he like literally
lined his entire house in Versace tile
even the top of the poker table right so
like the cards are flying off because
you want you like made this worse right
then he goes at a gambling Bender loses
a shitload of money decides the tile's
bad luck as it all ripped out of the
[__] house anyway so the guy's
capable of whatever right see text me or
calls me and it's like I don't know man
two in the morning and I'm like in bed
with a chick and like I'm not coming
over there he said come over I got you a
[__] present it's [__] amazing and
blah blah
Mike Brock I'll be over tomorrow like
I'm sure you know can wait he's like no
I can't wait he's like come on over blah
blah I'm like what is it he's like I'm
not telling you it's a secret now you
know I've given this guy like Ferraris
and [__] Audemars watches and [__] so
like when we gave each other gifts it
was pretty significant events
and uh so I knew it was like something
crazy because it was so [__] excited
about it and anyways I'm like finally
I'm like okay fine I'm like maybe
getting the cars I'm not getting in the
[__] car because she knew like when
we went over to his house like a black
hole like you would go there and like
maybe like you just like wouldn't leave
for [__] two days but you'd leave a
lot richer but like you know it was this
whole thing and you never knew what was
happening like there could be [__]
hookers running around like it'd be
spraying them with baby oil I mean like
paying them to hit golf balls into the
neighbor's house I mean the guy was out
of his [__] mind right and so he
tells me he's like he finally spits it
out there's a reason I decided to go
over there and say I got [__] tiger
sharks I got one for you and me in there
they're gonna be like brothers they're
gonna live together forever and all this
whole [__] thing and I'm like what
he's like yeah I got your tiger sharks
come on over and I'm like
[__] I'm like okay the guy's got tiger
sharks coming to see him you know so get
in the car drive over there and I'm like
on the way over there I'm wondering like
[__] this guy build like a [__] you
know five million aquarium in his house
but we're [__] is he gonna put tiger
sharks in I mean like just drawing out
all these things in my mind I'm like I'm
legitimately curious uh but I know he
has him because he says he's got [__]
got him and the guy's like if he says
he's got him he's got him so I go over
there and it's [__] look at his pool
he's got three [__] like king-sized
tiger sharks [__] in the pool there's
like Fish Bones and [__] in there I'm
just like what the [__] and uh and I go
over the shower and there's like this
big [__] shark and I like kind of
like oh like Curious like like kind of
like grab by the tail and like thing
doesn't move then like grab it again and
give it like a [__] jerk and like
blood comes out of the gills I'm like
bro like [__] shark is dead man like
what the [__] and uh and he's like what
do you mean and I'm like dude the shark
is dead I'm like this is a [__] pool
like what are you doing you can't put
like tiger sharks in there like there's
salt water animals and he like looks at
me he's like you don't think I thought
of that like I'm the idiot and I'm like
I like look in the bottom of this pool
this [__] guys throwing like Morton's
salt shakers like he's like throwing all
this salt in this house in the pool he's
like so [__] up on boy that he like
really believes that he's like turn this
into a saltwater pool so he killed tiger
sharks yeah like unknowing like that's
how [__] up this guy was he wanted to
hear that story I wanted to hear the
story yeah and then they were in there
for like two weeks until like his
[__] like just stinking it was just
it was horrible it was like yeah this
guy yeah he was he was legitimately out
of his mind he did more cocaine than
anybody I've ever met and it's not even
close like he would have like I remember
one time we were playing poker and this
dude like delivers a duffel bag of
cocaine and I'm just like look at this
thing like what's in there it's like oh
it's a little little bit of [__] blow
or something and I like open it up it
was like [__] just kilos I mean this
is like if if if somebody would have
[__] like found this they're like
this dude's like one of the biggest drug
dealers in L.A it was like for personal
Supply like he didn't sell it like this
is just for him yeah I mean where do
people like that where do people with
700 million dollars who do they buy Blow
from I don't know I mean it's like Pablo
Escobar this [__] guy because I've
never seen this much coke in my life
like literally just like bricks of it
and it was funny because you would watch
him do it and he would go through so
much coke a day but I would say only
like tearing it well like only like 10
to 20 would actually get up his [__]
nose right like like most of it ended up
on a shirt or in the air like you would
just get like contact high I remember
using a helicopter and like this [__]
Coke all over there and the Pilot's like
going crazy like dude what are you doing
you know like it's just in the [__]
air ventilation system and she was just
so messy with it but he didn't give a
[__] because he had like an endless
supply but the point is that like he
would still do more than would like kill
a normal person but like most of it was
on his clothes and around the house like
and you said this guy was terminally ill
yeah he had some like rare autoimmune
disease so he had I think it was like
eight years to live or some some short
period of time well eight years is the
max but he was like supposed to die in
two years or something and so he was
just like hell bent I'm blowing this
money he lost 82 million bucks gambling
one year I mean I was like how I got in
with this guy I was over at Nick cast of
Eddie's house and we were [__] and I
was like losing and um and this [__]
guy walks in and I was like down 150
1000 which for Nick's game was a lot
like the buying was like 10 grand and
this guy walks in and Nick's like oh
like you know you get even tonight and
I'm like yeah go [__] yourself and he's
like no no seriously I'm like yeah [__]
you he would always bust my balls
anyways this guy comes in and just
starts betting fifty thousand dollars
without looking at his cards and he like
get lost like 50 000 with two like two
like two two hands had been dealt he's
already down 50 Grand before the first
Orbee lost 100 and then he starts going
all in without looking at his cards and
I'm like look at Nick I'm like what the
[__] is going on with this guy and that
was the first first time I met him was
like him just going off like that and so
then he would like invite me to his
house and we would play heads up poker
and he was hopeless like the guy was
just like he wouldn't look at his cards
he was like he was like so distracted
bring over girls he's like so distracted
with the [__] girls all he cared
about was like getting [__] and like
it's the first time you met him at
Nick's house is he doing coke in that
game there's massive amounts of coke
yeah
he'd cook all over his nose look like
he's like eating powdered Donuts you
know and when he walks in the door and
this is a guy's like sweating profusely
like wearing all black and uh it was
funny that he always wore all black
because the coke would show up all over
his clothes like anyway so he actually
went to the bathroom
comes back and he's like [__] rips
another one and he's like playing and
whatever and like Nick's assistant comes
over to Nick and he's like hey like I
think there's like you know some [__]
you know dog [__] on the floor whatever
Nick's like okay we'll [__] clean it
up like leave me alone I'm playing poker
guy comes back like a few minutes later
I can hear what he's saying to Nick
because he's close to me and um he's
like wow he's like um
I gotta tell you like you know I I think
like [__] Sam [__] on the floor you
know and he's like stomped around and
you know he's like tracking it through
the house and they say okay like go
clean it up and I'm just like sitting
there like
this dude took a [__] on your floor and
he stumbled it through the house and
you're not gonna do anything about it so
I'm like tell Nick I'm like bro you just
uh you just let people just [__] all
over your house huh you're like listen
[__] this dude's down seven
hundred thousand dollars
I'll never forget that I was like yeah I
was like Fair Point that's that's
fantastic do you like shopping on Amazon
I do and good news is Stevo's butt wipes
for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude